Wawa's headquarters is a grand sprawling
campus in south china and last year in
an exclusive interview with Sky News its
founder Ren Zhong Fame had the
confidence to match his surroundings
what do they see Odin body shop or that
warned me oh she she did so poorly
person be so so cool
bow his thing all that should in the end
he was half right the British government
did initially say yes but then today it
said actually no mr. Ren told Sky News
he would refuse any demand from the
Chinese Communist Party to spy on its
customers Huawei has always insisted it
is a private company not an arm of the
state but for a private company the
Chinese government takes a great deal of
interest number way whether the UK can
provide an open fair and
non-discriminatory business environment
for Chinese companies will be the
touchstone of the trend in the UK market
after breakfast it as well as a
barometer of the safety of Chinese
investment in the UK China will pay
close attention to it thinly veiled
economic threats like that only
underline quoi ways importance to China
it is China's only truly global
technology company and more importantly
a world leader in a sensitive
cutting-edge sector its products are
ubiquitous in the country itself for
Chinese people it's also an emblem of
the country's development even though
you do
so Chancellor lui
cannon boy using idiots
daebak you don't know koala yeah turn
arrow may Ry Cooder Deirdre blah blah
there's no evidence that Huawei has
spied on the West but the underlying
worry is that here in China private
businesses are any private up to a point
as successful as well.we is it
ultimately like everyone else must
answer to the party at its headquarters
in Shenzhen Huawei built this a replica
of Wyndemere in the Lake District in the
long term a simulacrum of the UK may be
the extent of its involvement Tom
Cheshire Sky News Beijing